le dicton du jour à la saint denis qui
se vivent astérix comme le beaujolais
l'astérix nouveau est arrivé 30e album
des aventures de l'irréductible petit
gaulois des aventures déjà traduites en
77 langues et vendu au total à 280
millions d'exemplaires à travers la
planète
reportage m'a tuer chez josée bastien
albert uderzo a beau avoir mis au monde
30 astérix en bon père de famille il
vient lui même contrôlé les derniers
préparatifs
demain le dernier né de la saga arrive
en librairie avec un tirage pharaonique
près de 30 millions d'exemplaires en
france et 8 million en europe pour un
succès commercial préparé dans le plus
grand secret mais quelques heures avant
la naissance
le créateur de ces gaulois devenu star
reste tendue je vous dirai après le 10
octobre
si les choses vont bien encore pour moi
et pour astérix mais avant je ne sais
pas je sais que ça bien mort fait pour
le précédent celui ci ma foi toutatis
nous protège
j'espère que cela fera encore et dans
cet album c'est le livreur de menhirs
obélix qui tient la vedette
profitant d'un moment d'inattention du
druide obélix réussit enfin à engloutir
le chaudron de potion magique un
breuvage à haut risque pour ce garçon un
peu enveloppé qui était tombé dedans
petit transformée en statue obélix
commence sa galère mais comme d'habitude
tous se retrouveront autour d'un
sanglier
tous sauf un certain chanteur mal-aimé
dernier journal vers minuit x